la crisis sanitaria generó un
enfrentamiento entre la administración
central y la regional el gobierno
madrileño anunció que ampliaría las
restricciones a ocho zonas de salud más
de la capital una situación que mantiene
a madrid como el epicentro del rebrote
en españa' ya que concentra al 40% de
los casos a nivel general recomendamos
evitar todo viento necesario les puedo
decir que 8 nuevas zonas básicas de
salud cumple nuestros requisitos por lo
que en total serán 45 las áreas en las
que se adoptarán las medidas de control
y prevención ya conocidas la polémica ha
llegado con la contestación del ministro
de sanidad aunque las competencias de
salud residen en las regiones el
ejecutivo central defiende confinar a
toda la capital sin excepciones las
restricciones en madrid comienzan cuando
los sectores superan los mil contagios
por cada 100.000 habitantes pero el
gobierno cree que deberían comenzar con
los 500 contagios por cada 100.000
habitantes y yo creo que en unas semanas
duras en madrid
si lo tengo que trasladar
también en otras partes del territorio
de españa y por tanto hay que actuar con
determinación y en tres palabras para
tomar el control y hay que decir esto no
hay otro atajo no hay otro atajo no vale
en esos momentos un cierto hay que un
cierto gradualismo hay que actuar con
determinación y esto es lo que el
gobierno de españa traslada hoy a los
ciudadanos y zonas de la comunidad de
madrid y el conjunto del país la
polémica en torno a los
condicionamientos parciales en madrid ha
salpicado a su presidenta isabel díaz
ayuso ya que numerosos sectores aseguran
que solamente se ha confinado a los
distritos más humildes a pesar de que
los datos de toda la capital son muy
negativos algo que generó numerosas
protestas